arnold in an interview goes out there
and tells in the interview screw your
freedom this is a hollywood reporter
story he gave his fellow americans a
blunt message this week screw your
freedom the former governor of
california an actor was adamant about
his stance on cover 19 safety
precautions says there's a virus here it
kills people and the only way we we
prevent it is to get vaccinated to wear
masks do social distancing washing your
hands all the time and not just to think
about it well my freedom is being kind
of disturbed here no screw your freedom
because with freedoms comes of
obligations
and responsibilities you cannot just say
i have the right to x y and z when you
affect other people then it gets serious
the responsibility is similar to the
following rules at a traffic light so no
one gets killed the former governor said
so that's arnold's commentary now i got
some thoughts on this but i want to hear
your thoughts gerard what do you think
about what arnold said
to screw your freedom oh man i i two
things go through my mind i'm i'm the
biggest arnold guy in the world too and
and three things go through my mind
first of all
former republican governor of california
so there you go you want a recall by the
way yeah three three former republican
governor of california so you know it
goes to adam's it's both sides things
it's very clearly there there is this
this you know elite aristocracy and then
there's the rest of us unsophisticated
plebeians who that we we have to get
cattle herded into these cattle cars
we've got to get this shot but they can
have their 700 person uh parties in
martha's vineyard with no masks because
you know they they earned the freedom
there well they're probably all
vaccinated yeah yeah because that worked
out for them 75 of them are sick now but
anyway the
point i'm trying to make here is man
it's you the christopher nolan line in
in the dark knight you either either die
the hero you live long enough to see
yourself become the villain how can this
guy
who grew up in in the shadow of
totalitarian europe all right he grew up
after nazi germany and with
uh uh the ussr the steel curtain
literally above him and he has been here
for 60 years every one of his dreams
came true thanks to the freedoms of this
country and now that he's on the back
nine he's like screw your freedoms screw
your freedoms i've gotten everything i
wanted if they worked for me screw your
freedoms now don't make me sick like
it's the most it's the most narcissistic
thing that i've ever heard somebody say
it was the most tone-deaf thing i've
ever heard somebody say
and this is not a dumb guy he's an
incredibly intelligent man a dumb guy
you know and i'm wondering if somebody
got to him i'm wondering if there's
what's going on behind the scenes with
these bill burr has a whole bid on him
being a great man it's one of the
funniest comedy bits of all time it's
hilarious if you've never heard it of
course i've heard multiple times well
look i'd love to hear bill burr's
commentary on this because
you know what
the i don't know bill
this is one of the things that that you
could actually do to make you no longer
a great man adam what do you think yeah
well i mean you grew up you said you
were
you're a hero of arnold you literally
wanted to be arnold yep growing up so
i was never like a big
arnold guy obviously i watched total
recall and terminator i was like but i
never
looked up to arnold being from florida i
was never you know you're from
california he was your governor for
however many years how long was he the
governor when you were living there
eight years yeah so i've never used a
recall governor but yeah i'm not total
recall i've never had this fascination
with arnold
um
i guess my question is does he have a
point at all clearly his past history
coming from
austria or whatever the iron curtain and
now having living the most amazing life
ever united states obviously his
perspective has changed significantly in
the last 50 years i guess my question is
does he have a point and if he does do
do you look at him any differently pat
yeah so a couple different things for me
here couple different things for me here
when i think about like in the world of
bodybuilding arnold's a hero erin
singerman the founder c of uh retconn
who gave a half a million dollars to the
trump obama
interview
you know he made a video yesterday very
respectful very fair but he called him
out he said we're no longer doing a
sponsorship with arnold classic anymore
and he cut out hundreds of thousands of
dollars he does every other arnold
classic this is not a regular small
company it's a pretty big that's a
company and he says i'm sorry i don't
support he says you have the right to
say that but i have the right to not
sponsor you i'm not doing it this year
he pulled out right retcon and he's got
kai greene all these other guys and kai
greens and arnold classic guy you know
so it's all the stuff that's taking
place
here's here's how i see this uh with
with arnold i have a very big challenge
with what he said
his poster has been on my walls in my
army barracks all over the place okay i
had his poster everywhere i have his
poster that had in the army till today
it's in my stash i've kept it right
because it was like something you got to
keep from 1998 1999 when i was at the
101st airborne division about every
magazine every year muscle mag or flex
would do special on arnold i'd buy all
of them they'd have a poster in the
middle of it i've read total recall we
made total recall book of the month to
read in the entire company we've ordered
6 000 copies of his book we had everyone
read an 800 page book i don't know if
you've read it or not where he goes
through explaining the whole story how
the first i think the building he bought
in palmdale or how he decided again to
real estate the stories of joe wieder he
thought it was such a big headquarters
until he comes in town he knows us joel
wieder's office was like a small shack
it's like wow joe was really able to
sell this thing this friendship with
franco colombo his experience with his
dad when he's about to go compete for mr
universe and all of a sudden his father
passes away and he has to choose whether
he goes to pursue mr universe or he goes
back to the funeral he chooses to go to
bodybuilding competition then comes up
hey you will never be an actor you sound
weird you don't sound right and he says
no i'm going to do it then he goes and
buries the kennedy then he goes out
there becomes a governor he goes up and
becomes the highest paid actor at one
point he was making 20 a movie he was
the highest paid actor before
his 90s exactly there was a rock it was
arnold like everybody followed this
guy's playbook but here's a challenge
here's a challenge on what happens when
you start making money and you have fame
and i think this is what's going on with
them there's a few things that happens
to you at this phase of your life okay
you your worries change your worries
change from
man am i free to go out there and have
my dreams become a reality all of those
checks have been done already check mark
check mark check money now it's about am
i going to get a nobel am i going to get
another prize am i going to be invited
to the obama birthday party am i going
to get on the good list of this am i
going to get on the good list of that
because at this point what else do you
have like you see
what else do you have no no it's it's
more it's not even the legacy part
because saying screw your freedom what
the hell do you mean screw your freedom
bro what are you talking about screw
your freedom okay so screw your freedom
william bonac is from ghana okay william
bonak won 2018 arnold classic okay your
competitors rolly
you know you got the joshua is from
australia joshua lennartowicz we know
what's going on in
in australia right now how about hari
shapon hari chopin who is an iranian
bodybuilder go explain to him screw your
freedom go explain to him what's going
on in iran right now with screw your
frame what the hell do you mean screw
your freedom i think it's out of touch i
think he is trying to please an audience
i don't know why
i think standing up he was very brave to
stand up against trump and make those
videos and say all the stuff that he
said but nowadays he's just trying to
uh you know win the wrong audience and i
don't know what is going on through his
mind when he does this nobody knows the
whole story he he was your hero have you
lost respect for him where where's he at
on your mantle right now yeah you know
what it you know what it is to me it's
it's
when you forget like listen when when a
person okay so for example i have uh we
just had a conventional last week right
in las vegas
one of the things i remind my guys to
follow and i said listen i don't care if
you make a half a million a year a
million year 10 million a year 20
million a year the day you can no longer
relate to the 15 an hour person you lose
the game
the movie the movie
gladiator where marcus aurelius not
marcus aurelius where gladius maximus is
asking his owner he says i want to earn
my freedom what did he say win the crowd
when what when the hearts when the when
the crowd win your freedom right okay
great
arnold you won the crowd
you won your freedom did you forget
did you forget what a italian regime did
to you did you forget what it was like
being where you were at we have no say
you can't say anything like that the way
you just did right now you can't get on
a video and say certain things in
certain countries you know what's going
on in afghanistan how scared people are
go explain to those guys screw your
freedom yeah the guys go go go tell them
go people go go tell the woman in
in afghanistan hey sorry you can't go to
school anymore your dream was to be a
journalist one girl they're interviewing
she's speaking eloquently in english
better than i speak in english and she
says one of my dreams is i told my
journalist boss that i work for i said
one day i want to own that chair i want
to be sitting in your chair because i
want to be like you a boss a woman
saying that in afghanistan guess what
she could do that last week it's over
she can no longer do that
kids are going through what they're
going through right now girls are afraid
a guy's being interviewed he says i am
afraid for my life me and my sister are
living together my dad they got killed
my mom got killed i'm by myself he's
shivering
shivering while they're screaming in the
back death upon america yeah screw your
freedom arnold what the hell happened
with perspective what happened with
perspective are you just trying to get
aligned with your best friend tom hanks
and some of these other guys i'm sorry
this is what bothers me the most look
we're friends yes
okay we can hang out have a conversation
together right
dude no matter how much i love you i'm
not going to compromise how much i
respect capitalism no matter how much i
love you cannot change my mind on
capitalism capitalism is capitalism no
matter who's my i love my mother
she cannot change my thoughts on
communism not being a good system i love
my mom she's in the top three list of
people top seven people i got four kids
now top seven eight people in my life
even a woman i love can i change my
values on what i saw happen to her
family what happened to different
countries and what happened to us coming
over to america i'm an iranian guy what
the hell are we doing here because we
escaped something we escaped something
go ahead and explain screw your freedom
so for me the moment you cross that line
where you say something like that just
because you want a one-liner on cnn a
guy was messaging me saying the only
reason he said that is because he is
becoming irrelevant and he wants to kind
of get some uh what do you call it uh
i disagree with that arnold's never
going to be relevant arnold's a governor
you know highest paid actors in the top
list you know married to kennedy seven
times strong olympia the guy's legacy is
stacked he's got a resume that's
very few people in america have the
guy's resume very very few people
he has an opportunity today to actually
unite america
a guy like arnold could be a synergist
but he's becoming a guy that's dividing
there used to be time where people would
tell me
don't say things like that because he
may never do an interview with you my
dream in my life is not to interview
arnold yeah i don't wake up in the
morning saying oh my gosh let me say all
the right things because i'm walking on
excels god forbid i offend arnold
because he will never do an interview i
don't care
that's not my mo
what my mo is freedom and knowing the
fact that the people in america that
forgot how special this country is to be
re-reminded the last seven days
you look at australia you look at the
afghanistan you look at haiti those are
three signs to remind you how
ridiculously incredible of a country
america is one is infrastructure when's
the last time you saw an earthquake
bringing down and 1400 people dying in
america i lived in l.a earthquakes
happen all the time how come we don't
have that kind of stuff strong
infrastructure next one is what
freedoms that we have women we celebrate
women victories here we celebrate woman
go when's the last time you even thought
about a woman cannot be a lawyer or a
doctor that's that's over there though
so the the message of what arnold said
to me is a lot deeper than just hey
screw your freedom it's a lot deeper
message and uh uh for the people are
like well you know pat he's probably
never gonna sit down with you that's not
my goal so i've got a crazy idea
uh adam's gonna put up five million
dollars we're gonna do a sit down
[Music]
arnold we're gonna get it going it's
unfortunate because this guy's a hero
this guy's a hero this guy's a man i
admired a lot if you you touched on this
briefly
if he actually wanted to be a synergist
what would be in his playbook what kind
of what kind of rhetoric what is kind of
this the mindset of a synergist
what give me the number one quality of a
synergist they're willing to listen they
respect both sides that's that's a
synergist and he's not but they but they
actually you have to you can't fake that
respect no you have to genuinely respect
both sides and these quote unquote
elites i keep talking about they very
clearly don't respect anybody else
you don't have to you don't have to
respect
let me choose my words carefully you
don't have to respect what they're
saying but you can respect their right
to say it so daryl davis the the guy the
black man that sits down with the kkk
hates everything that comes out of their
mouth sure but he's willing and has
enough respect for them to say hey look
you're entitled to your thoughts you're
entitled to your opinions but just to
just to be clear here though we're not
we're not comparing
people who want the right to their
bodily autonomy to the kkk
no it's just
i think it comes down to respect look
you respect other people i sat down with
david horowitz i don't know if you know
what david horowitz is he's the father
of ben horowitz his son is worth three
and a half billion dollars david
horowitz is a legendary
author wrote a different books and he
started the interview these democrats
are commies i said david you can't say
that they are i said you can't say that
i said you think you're going to be able
to change people's minds by calling
democrats comments i'm sorry this whole
thing with the taliban in afghanistan
guess what hillary said to biden don't
do it
hillary's a democrat to me hillary's a
democrat democrat like a real democrat
right minus all the favors and all the
money with haiti and all that other mess
that she did you know on the crazy side
that she is with a lot of controversy
that comes
she came out she said don't do it don't
don't pull out of afghanistan condorees
arrives don't pull out of afghanistan
maybe both of them have a little bit of
experience to know it's not a good idea
to pull out the way you pulled out
they're democrats so there was a no but
all democrats are communists no so
comments like that yeah when you make
you ain't converting nobody likes zero
zero yeah when you say screw your
freedom the hell you do like do you
think that so think about that common
force you're playing to your base is
what you're saying what is the matter
with you people that already agree with
you are just gonna continue to agree
with you cares to do that
i'm a die hard laker fan do i sit there
and say lakers can't do anything wrong
no it's not my style so i can say all
the good things about lakers for them to
be what do you call it bulletproof
it's just not my style so you know this
is why when you
hear people from their own side calling
at somebody on their own side they gain
credibility like tucker said look i
think uh we should have left afghanistan
a long time ago but the way we did it
was wrong so what's he saying he's
agreeing that hey we should saw that
yeah so you got to kind of say hey
listen good times or even bill maher or
even jon stewart recently calling out
your own side arnold had an opportunity
to be one of the biggest synergists in
america he screwed up arnold screw your
freedom is what you say you screwed up
your chance to be a synergist and
synergist to me is way above
being a voice for the republican or the
democratic party it's way above let me
ask you this though because i'm of the
opinion and i agree not all democrats
are communists but i do believe to in my
heart that there are died in the wool
communists in the democratic party right
now that are posing as democrats i don't
disagree and i think that we have to out
there but but but i don't disagree with
that but the word the key word is what
what's the key word
all are no you're not you're not right
i got i run a company where we got
the other day we're at the hakasam this
girl comes up says pat you know i love
you yeah but adam's my favorite right
yeah i'd like to have you but adam is my
favorite you know what guess what i love
it because it's discussion this debate
is this course i'm comfortable with that
as long as we're having these real
conversations together guess what more
power to you i like you you do have a
shocking amount of like socialists that
follow you like not democrats like you
have a shocking amount
because you interview socialists
i will interview a communist a socialist
i will interview just about anybody tell
me i'll sit down with them i'm very
comfortable with that because to me i
think a good debate is where people
learn and my goal is more to be a
synergist in life than to be a
you know person that's used by political
party just because hey go up there and
let's use this guy ah yeah you can use
me i'm totally fine with that i think
man upstairs is using certain people but
the message i'm gonna say is a message
that's gonna be what i really believe in
some of it you're gonna like some of
you're not gonna lie i think that's
really noble but i mean i i just i feel
like these guys use that kindness as a
weakness i feel like especially in this
moment
look just call it what it is we're going
we're living through a global communist
revolution we are we are living through
china on the move china over no question
about it into becoming the world's
there's no question about china making
that they're making the move all right
and
they're they're hiding their true
intentions and they've been doing this
for a decade under the guise of other
things it's not communism it's
humanitarianism it's not communism it's
the green new deal it's not communism
it's black lives matter it's not
communism it's it if your
ideology is so noble if your world view
is so good why do you constantly have to
hide your intentions
that to me is the biggest red flag of
all if this grand ideal this utopian
egalitarian ideal is so good why do you
constantly have to lie about what it is
and that that to me is the big red flag
and if we don't call it out if we don't
say no no no no no this has nothing to
do with climate crisis now it's gone for
in the last 10 years has gone from
global warming to climate change to the
climate crisis and i'm not saying that
it doesn't exist all i'm saying is the
messaging is getting more and more and
more extreme okay
the reasoning behind it now becomes oh
we have to completely change all the
industries into our control and all of
the money that you earn and money just
represents the hours of your life so all
the hours of your life now come into my
control and let's say aoc for example
okay
how does me giving you all my money
change the weather
you gotta prove your work there you
gotta show your work how you can't just
make blanket statements where this is
the climate crisis we need to act now
okay
give me 90 of your income and i'll make
the weather change okay bartender how
tell me how i'm not saying no tell me
how it's just it's communism under these
different names they are using what's
the last thing you watch in 1984. i i
read the book i read the book i read uh
orwell once a year depending on what
have you read it you ever read it or not
yeah back in the day five i i don't
think we're living 384 i think we're
living through fahrenheit 451. have you
have you do you remember the story or no
yeah and there was also what was the the
animal farm uh yeah that's that's
another welcome yeah
animal farm's just an allegory for the
bolshevik revolution yeah it's you know
it's
the biggest thing is the biggest thing
is to be to not be naive about what is
going on today so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]